Next we will be working
with boolean arrays.
In simple terms arrays with
values true and false.
This can also be used for indexing.
Indexing using boolean arrays is very
different as compared to index arrays,
we learned previously.
Imagine a situation where we want to
get all the values from the array,
which is less than mean
of the entire array.
The first step to solve this problem
would be to calculate the mean.
Consider a two dimensional array.
As we learned before,
we will calculate the mean using
the mean attribute of the array a.
Let's check what the mean is.
According to our problem,
we want all the values from
the area which is less than mean.
Mean is 14.2.
You can imagine that the solution would
contain values 10, 10 again, 5, 0,
0 again, 2, and so on and so forth.
If you need all these values,
one way is to run the for
loop over the array, and get them.
But using masking,
we do this in one single line.
To read this operation, it would be for
each value in array A,
compare it with the mean.
If it is less, we retain the value.
Let's check the output.
Here is the values which we
expected in the form of list.
Now to go ahead with this concept,
we can also replace these
values with the mean value.
We just assign the mean value to
masking operation we performed before.
Let's see the output.
Observe that all the values
previously less than mean
have been replaced by the mean.
This is one of the important operation
that shows the power of the and
justifies its extensive use throughout.